despite the fact that Wilson had just
won re-election in 1916 based on a
platform of keeping the United States
out of war by April by April of 1917 the
administration had decided that Germany
had gone too far and in particular had
gone too far with the unrestricted
submarine warfare so this right over
here is a picture of President Wilson on
April 2nd 1917 giving a war message to
Congress as to why the US needs to
declare war on Germany and April 4th
Congress passes the resolution to
declare war and then the president
approves it on April 6 so by early April
the United States was at war with
Germany which is a good time to start
thinking about why did all of this
happen now the things that are typically
cited and these are the things that are
inflamed public opinion in the US and
that many of which were cited by
President Woodrow Wilson and in this
tutorial that this is part of on
khanacademy.org I put the entire text of
his speech which I highly recommend
reading to see all of the things that
President Wilson cited in his speech but
just as a summary of that that things
that tend to get cited most often are
the unrestricted submarine warfare on
the part of Germany unrestricted
submarine warfare and particular cases
or the most cited example of that is the
sinking of the Lusitania the Germans had
stopped doing that for a little under
two years but then as we enter into into
1917 they began doing it again and it
also made the Americans quite angry to
realize that the Germans were trying to
incite the Mexicans against them so you
have the Zimmerman you have the
Zimmermann telegram Zimmermann telegram
is also a reason that the Wilson
administration and why the why people in
general were fairly angry about things
now on top of that there were there were
atrocities committed by the Germans in
their march through Belgium as they were
trying to execute on this leaf and plan
so Belgian Belgian atrocities and these
were an earlier in the war 1914 which
immediately made
any Americans kind of not like what's
going on Belgian atrocities and to put
on top of that the you the British were
able to leverage the Belgian atrocities
to do to fairly to execute a fairly
effective propaganda campaign in in
America now on top of that and this is
something that Wilson speaks very
strongly about in a speech is the notion
of fighting for democracy fighting for
fighting for democracy and what you have
here in firt in the first world war the
Central Powers if we talk about the
German Empire you're talking about the
austro-hungarians these are monarchies
these are emperors who are controlling
it and even though the UK the United
Kingdom was nominally a kingdom it was
really a democracy at least for those
who could vote we're not talking about
the entire British Empire so UK is
functionally a democracy democratic and
so was the third French Republic and so
was and so was fans so there's this
argument that the u.s. is fighting for
the represent the representation of
people now there is a more cynical
argument that some people have made and
I think it's reasonable to give that do
time and one of the cynical arguments or
more cynical arguments is that the US
had close financial and trade ties to
Britain not to mention cultural ties
financial ties to the British on top of
that you had very successful British
propaganda the one talking about the
atrocities in Belgium which did actually
happen but the British were able to
exploit this as a propaganda machine
successful propaganda but they also
spread rumors that after the sinking of
Luce of the Lusitania that the Germans
had their schools children celebrating
and these were all made up propaganda
proper propaganda and then cynical zat's
in a more kind of cynical view of why
the u.s. entered the war and this is
true of probably most Wars is that there
was a lot of lobbying on the part of war
profiteers war profiteers in fact in
Little Orphan Annie Daddy Warbucks the
name reason why his last name is
Warbucks is because he made
he made his fortune as a war profiteer
during World War one in war profiteers
these are people who might be selling
arms to the Allies or who might sell
arms to the US government if the US were
to get into a war that might somehow
supply the troops and it includes
potentially folks in wall street there
was significant lending to the Allies
and mainly the Allies not the not the
central power and so the view is that
the Allies win those loans are going to
be made good and I have the entire text
of the speech from senator senator
George Norris who was one of five
senators or sorry one of six senators to
vote against the resolution to go to war
there were 50 represent 50
representatives who also voted against
it this is a little excerpt but also in
this tutorial I have the full text of a
speech and I highly highly highly
recommend reading that along with
Wilson's text of his speech to Congress
in his war in his war message but I'll
just read this part because it does I
think point out that the u.s. from the
beginning did have biases that were more
Pro British and so this is part of his
Beach the reason given by the President
and asking Congress to declare war
against Germany is that the German
government has declared certain war
zones within which by the use of
submarines she sinks without notice
American ships and destroys American
lives the first war zone was declared by
Great Britain
she gave us and the world notice of it
on the fourth day of November 1914 the
zone became effective November 5th 1914
this saw this zone so declared by Great
Britain covered the whole of the North
Sea the first German war zone was
declared on the fourth day of February
1915 just three months after the British
war zone was declared Germany gave 15
days notice of the establishment of her
zone which became effective on the 18th
day of February 1915 the German war zone
covered the English Channel and the high
sea waters around the British Isles it
is unnecessary to cite authority to show
that both of these orders declaring
military zones were illegal and contrary
to international law it is sufficient to
say that our government has officially
declared both of them to be illegal and
officially protested against both of
them the only difference is that in the
case of Germany we have persisted in our
protest while in the case of England we
have submitted I encourage you once
again to read to read the text of both
Wilson's speech and and and senator
norris's speech and come up to your with
your own decisions and it might be a
little bit of both